okay now thank you so much my only
question is like I know that you've
spent so long with me and I think this
is the first podcast that you've done
since that story well it's a thank you
and why like what do I do to deserve
this it's an honor for me
um
I look I'm I'm not pissing in your
pocket here Kurt when I say that I love
your show because you let people talk
and you have a an understanding of
science because of your training in
physics and you ask good questions you
know you've put me on the spot at times
where you've asked me to justify what
I've said I like being put on the spot
um it's fun it's what journalists should
do and the irony is it's a show like
yours that's doing the job that
major newspapers and television in
mainstream should be doing
and so what's happening at the moment is
we're seeing a shift
my daughters God bless them they don't
watch TV news my wife and I watched the
six o'clock news every night and the TV
news and we like to see the network news
you know and we know the news anchor and
we read the newspaper and we're
religious about following the news every
day but I think we're the last
generation that are going to do that
one of my daughters told me she gets
most of her news from Tick Tock
um okay uh Instagram I mean I've had to
learn they've Robbie Williams of all
people followed me on um Instagram the
other day and recommended me to his
audience and my daughter who's a social
media marketer basically came to me and
said Dad
Robbie Williams followed you and I went
what does that mean sorry and she went
huge you know you should use Instagram
more and I went what's Instagram you
know I'm honestly truly I created an
Instagram account years ago to basically
monitor
um pictures of dogs that my wife sends
me but um I have to admit I've never
really used it for use dissemination and
what fascinates me is that there's a
younger generation that is impatient
with mainstream media they don't care
about it anymore they don't watch the
news they don't listen to Network
television or radio and those news
organizations are losing their audience
like when I first started in networked
television
I mean Australia is only a country of um
27 million people but one of the biggest
stories I ever did was a corruption
exposure and I think we got nearly three
million
views which was just massive huge chunk
of the national audience
and these days
a really good rating is 500 000 views in
network television
and the reason why I think is because
they're not doing the sort of stories
that you and I are interested in the
kind of long-form discursive analysis
that you do
it's not for any coincidence that shows
like yours are doing really well and
drawing millions of views it's because
people are impatient with old style
Legacy Media you just watched a clip
from the theories of everything channel
for the full video and all its
magnificence then click here and if
you'd like to see more then subscribe
enjoy